I'm genuinely glad to see that more
people are sounding the alarm about the
danger that Ron DeSantis or as some know
him wrong desanctus
uh poses to American democracy you know
I've been talking about this for a long
time and former guest on this program
expert on fascism Ruth Ben geot in
response to Jeb Bush endorsing Ron
DeSantis despite DeSantis not even being
a candidate at the time Ruth bengia
tweeted quote Ron DeSantis will destroy
our democracy with deadly Precision I
cannot emphasize enough how dangerous he
is so Ruth clearly comes down on the
side of what I've been saying for a year
now DeSantis is bad but the real danger
is that he's less incompetent than Trump
and thus is far more likely if he
becomes president to successfully
Implement a lot of these horrible and
disastrous ideas and increasingly the
proof is in looking at what he has done
in Florida for the last couple of yours
now in a later segment we're going to
deal with this in a sort of different
way but sort of like as a reminder
what exactly is it that DeSantis has
quote succeeded at doing in Florida the
don't say gay Bill the entire anti-woke
Feud with Disney disturbingly
authoritarian business Freedom except
when we don't like what the business is
doing when we don't like the opinion of
your business the plan to overhaul the
Board of Trustees at the historically
liberal new College of Florida with six
new hand-picked conservative members
chilling when it comes to what supposed
small government conservatives want to
do in putting their hands right into the
specifics of what higher uh learning
institutions higher education
institutions are doing trying to
manipulate and control what is in that
advanced placement black history course
that became the subject of much
controversy a few weeks ago but the core
of all of this is that Trump and
DeSantis are both sort of wannabe
authoritarians Trump gets easily
distracted and is very incompetent so
through a sort of like adult ADHD where
he ends up just watching the TV in the
back of the room and his incompetence he
doesn't end up getting that much done
and so many of Donald Trump's failings
in a sense were from just kind of not
paying attention
Ron DeSantis on the other hand is far
less likely to be ineffective for those
reasons the January 6th Insurrection had
it been run by DeSantis would have had a
greater chance of succeeding not a
guarantee it would have succeeded
probably still would not have but it
certainly would have had more of a shot
Trump also does a lot of things because
he wants his base to like him and his
interest trumps interest in a lot of the
things he thinks of doing is geared
around I think my base will like this
and I think people will praise me for it
DeSantis genuinely seems to have like a
culture War delusion that he has to win
and as we've talked about being a True
Believer in a sense makes you more
dangerous now I I want to then add
another caveat because this DeSantis is
a complicated guy DeSantis is not a dumb
guy in the way that Trump is kind of dim
and part of me wonders whether DeSantis
really believes any of it personally but
as long as he's committed to it because
it's what he believes he has to do for
political expediency and to succeed he
is still a True Believer that it's what
he should do even if personally he
thinks a lot of these things are kind of
dumb ideas so the big hope against
DeSantis and the dangers that he poses
uh basically comes down to his complete
and total lack of Charisma and we're
going to look at some examples of that
in a moment his complete and utter lack
of Charisma might make him ill-suited to
actually defeat Donald Trump in the
national campaign that we seem to be
barreling towards even though DeSantis
hasn't officially announced anything yet
it is genuinely tough to find a less
charismatic person than Ron DeSantis at
least among the people in the major
Spotlight right now so that's Ruth
bengia accurately concerned about the
threat that DeSantis poses to democracy
let's now see what Rhonda Santos has
been up to in this growing civil war
against Donald Trump